you are watching cold
in TV welcome to another ColdFusion
video to go go here let me ask your
question who built this building
it's the Burj Khalifa in Dubai currently
the world's tallest building okay not
quite sure what about this one these are
the Petronas Towers two iconic
skyscrapers in Malaysia well as it turns
out samsung built all of those
skyscrapers sometimes when you look
beneath the surface fact is often
stranger than fiction
the air is 1938 the Western financial
system was still recovering from one of
the greatest crashes in history and the
Second World War was about to break out
it wasn't such a rosy time but
regardless in the sea are a lesser known
man by the name of Lee Chou was about to
change the course of history he founded
a little company called Samsung a
trading company that dealt with local
groceries and had 40 employees at the
time the company produced noodles then
expanded into sugar and then wool and by
the late 1950s the company had moved
into insurance securities and retail in
the late 1960s Samsung moved into
electronics and the first ever product
produced by Samsung Electronics was
actually a 12-inch black-and-white TV in
1970 by 1983 the first Samsung computer
had arrived this computer was a full two
years ahead of Windows PCs in the 90s
samsung began to rise as an
international force in many industries
is my new computer going to be updated
in six months
with the new samsung note master gives
unique CPU can be easily replaced so you
can keep updating and stop worrying the
company went from strength to strength
becoming market leaders by learning the
trades of various industries through
persistence in the end they became one
of the most versatile companies in world
history today many of us use Samsung
products in our daily lives from TVs to
computers to smartwatches and digital
cameras to fridges and kitchenware to
the chips that run our mobile phones to
the actual phones themselves while this
diversity is very impressive for just
one company just how big is Samsung and
what else are they involved in we'll
make yourself comfortable guys and get
ready to be surprised
Samsung is much bigger than you think in
this video we'll take a look at some of
the awesome facts about the company and
then take a look at it's mind-boggling
size trust me it gets pretty crazy like
most of the stuff in this channel this
is the stuff you're not going to see
anywhere else on YouTube let's get into
it
number five since 1993 Samsung
Electronics has been the largest
producer of memory chips in the world in
fact the original iPhone and numerous
other devices run on Samsung
manufactured chips in addition to this
in 2011 Samsung became the world's
largest smartphone manufacturer number
four in Korean the word Samsung means
three stars the founder of Samsung Group
wanted to indicate that the company was
big powerful and numerous the Stars also
stood for eternity have a look at this
logo do you notice the opening on both
ends of the ellipse were the letters s
and G are located this is intended to
illustrate the company's open-mindedness
and desire to communicate with the world
number three
starting from 2006 Samsung remained the
largest television manufacturer in the
world they are also the largest
manufacturers of LCD panels and today
98% of the AMOLED screen market is
dominated by Samsung for those of you
wondering AMOLED is a type of screen
that doesn't require a backlight like
typical LCD screens number two the
company spent 14 billion dollars in
research and development in just 2014
alone another interesting thing the S at
the end of the Galaxy S series stands
for super smart
number one samsung has four hundred
ninety thousand employees more employees
than Apple Google and Microsoft combined
bonus in 1995 Samsung invested two
million dollars into the clothing brand
FUBU just as they were about to go under
FUBU has generated six billion dollars
in sales since okay so those are some
quick bite facts about the company some
pretty interesting stuff but let's go a
little bit deeper down the rabbit hole
things get a lot crazier so just how big
is Samsung well in terms of money the
company made 305 a billion dollars in
revenue in 2014 so is that good or not
so good we need a bit of a yardstick
here so how much was apples revenue in
2014 it was actually 183 billion and
what about Google only 66 billion well
that's not all Samsung is 17 percent of
Korea's entire GDP so the question must
be asked how do they make such
ridiculous amounts of money to dwarf
even Google well here's the secret
Samsung is actually made up of 80
different businesses and affiliates
these businesses are commercially and
legally independent but unified by
sharing a single philosophy here are
some of them under the category of
engineering and construction we have
Samsung engineering and construction
Samsung trading and investment and
Samsung Heavy Industries for electronics
we have Samsung Electronics
Samsung electro-mechanics techwin a
military arm Samsung mobile display and
Samsung digital imaging to name a fear
for Finance we have Samsung life
insurance securities investment trust
management venture investment there's
also a chemical branch Samsung
petrochemicals Samsung BP chemicals
there's actually plenty of others as
well like a marketing company called
Sherrill industries samsung also has a
hotel and resort business a medical
center Economic Research Institute a
foundation of culture a life and welfare
foundation in a joint venture at Renault
the company also has been making cars
for 20 years and the list goes on and on
and on okay so it's starting to get a
little bit crazy but what are some other
lesser-known things about Samsung what
else are they doing well you are in for
a treat so we've already mentioned that
Samsung build skyscrapers but what else
well under Samsung's branch samsung
techwin the company also does
surveillance Aeronautics automations
and weapons technology some of the
weapons technology that samsung has made
includes a South Korean military robot
designed to replace human counterparts
in the Demilitarized Zone at the south
and north korean border and that's not
all Samsung has also made the k-9 a
full-fledged army tank and if that
wasn't enough Samsung also makes jet
engines but let's turn things up a notch
as it turns out Samsung Heavy Industries
has the most efficient shipbuilding
Center in the entire world it is over
400 million square feet in size and
these are some of the ships that Samsung
has built over the years as you can see
by comparing them to a regular ship
these are absolute giants colossal
floating cities almost and if that's not
enough
Samsung runs the biggest theme park in
Korea complete with the zoo and various
other crazy things Samsung's size is so
ridiculous that there's even a Samsung
city this city contains a few of the
company's businesses some other cool
things include their very own clothing
line and a brand new research lab for
drones robotics 3d printing and virtual
reality the cool thing about this lab
is actually going to be part of
Samsung's mobile division but it's going
to operate independently and it's going
to build on the work that Samsung has
done through their robot vacuum cleaners
and let's not forget virtual reality in
general the gear VR was the first proper
mobile virtual reality headset and I
just got it the other day and I've been
playing around with it and it actually
works pretty well
ok so we're reaching towards the end of
the video so maybe you're starting to
get the picture now that Samsung does
just more than TVs fridges and phones
they do pretty much everything in all my
time of doing videos I've never come
across so many surprises in my research
and I'm not saying this to be a fanboy
or anything like this it's just a matter
of looking at how many things they do
who would have known that the same
company that dominates the smartphone
industry also makes jet engines and
military equipment builds some of the
world's biggest ships built the world's
biggest skyscraper has a medical
research facility a theme park a finance
institution and the list goes on and on
it's said that every year of Samsung
donates one hundred million dollars to
its nonprofit Medical Center which
consists of several hospitals and
medical research facilities
so in conclusion it would seem that
Samsung is the kind of company that
tries their hand at almost everything
and chooses to observe and iterate until
they get better and eventually become
the market leaders in all honesty it is
amazing how much of a dark horse this
company is I wouldn't be surprised if
most people out there are only aware of
Samsung Electronics and their home
appliances it's amazing to think that
all of this just started from one man
with his small trading company dealing
in groceries so if you have a Samsung
phone the next time you look at it it
might just seem a little bit different
now that you know the true size of the
company that made it anyway this has
been to go go I want to thank you for
watching and if you want to see any
other cool stuff on different companies
or alternative science and technology
news definitely feel free to subscribe
cheers guys I'll see you again soon from
the next video have a good one you gonna
say something well okay they were just
going to speaking don't you hey guys to
go go yeah thanks for watching the whole
way through the video that was insane
like actually when I was researching the
stuff on Samsung and
seeing what they got up to and what the
company really was about how big they
were that actually surprised me myself
so this kind of was a video that
educated me and hopefully educated you
as well and if that was the case let me
know down below if he actually found
something new that you didn't know about
Samsung in that video and I kind of wish
every company was this big and this
diverse I could do more videos on this
kind of thing but it just seems that our
Samsung was just the biggest out there
so that's why I chose this topic but
anyway that's enough of me talking
really just thank you for watching this
video and if you liked it give a thumbs
up don't forget to share it with someone
if you reckon they'll get something out
of this and I guess I'll see you again
soon for the next video thanks watching
guys see you later cold future are you
thinking